who was Noah Noah was a man uh he was
the guy that built the ark very
interesting ideas about boat
construction how big was Noah's Ark
really big super large ten football
fields 512 feet well I we was measured
with like arms so like a lot of those
300 x 50 by thirty cubits how big is a
cubic that part of the metric system
about the length of my elbow to my
knuckles here a cubit would be like a
group of elephants how many animals
could fit on the ark all of them 22 of
all of them two thousand probably
hundreds of thousands 5257 and what we
are made up would probably it floats
well would it's like a wood plus an
animal name also would so it flowed it
floated very well no stoned with water
got to survive water stone flow how long
did it take to build the ark a weekend
three-day weekend a month I think it's
like a whole year yeah at least 40 hours
a week how old was Methuselah
we died I think he was around 900 lat
tire leisure people live longer than but
Anthony Hopkins is playing in a movie
doesn't look a day over 230 240 how did
they repopulate not gonna go under the
way that everyone repopulate Shem ham
and Japheth wife's mammy all around the
arc no and I guess they've calculated
after that the animals or the humans
both bangin man they boned not very
carefully need a meeting sex tons of sex
they probably had sex got some candles
the put on some very white Dada my
father said that one day if man
continued in his way the Creator would
annihilate this world
what did he say it's going to destroy
the world missile would def my water I
had made up my back you stand alone and
he find me
I'm not Allah
we build an ark
it begins when they come that will be
desperate there will be many